foreign
question of the day comes from the
Ramsay steps Facebook group great
communities there on Facebook and this
person says what baby step would you
vote as the most important
whoa It's like picking our favorite
child I know
um that's a fun question this is
interesting you know this is very this
is opinion this is just put it out there
yes this is op-ed
um I would say that
this is like my my they're all important
it's very hard for me I mean they build
on each other right because it's a plan
so it's like one thing has to be true in
order for the next thing to be true so
on the one hand I'm like yes you've got
to get debt free like if you get debt
free that's changing your life but if
you get debt free and you never save for
retirement you're up a creek right so
I'm going to vote the non-vote oh vote
you can't do that okay well okay baby
step two is my favorite oh but it's not
the most important you put it out there
it's my favorite but it's not the most
important that's a good way to say it
they said most important though see well
George maybe you should just okay well
for those listening like what in the
Incarnation are they talking about right
now let me just lay them out real quick
so you can cast your vote America baby
step one thousand dollar starter
emergency fund baby step two get out of
all Consumer Debt using the debt
snowball method baby step three fully
funded emergency fund of three to six
months of expenses baby step four invest
fifteen percent of your household income
into retirement baby step five put away
some money for the kids college funds
then baby step six pay off the house
early and then baby step seven build
wealth and give and be outrageously
generous so I mean you can hear that
you're like which one is the most
important which uh
I'm gonna say the most important for
your financial future is baby step four
yes investing Building Wealth being able
to retire with dignity because that is
going to give you a great life you know
20 years from now for the next 30 years
after that that yeah but baby step two I
think is the most is my most favorite
and I think the most Paradigm Shift yeah
it's the most freeing yes you
know and
yeah that's that's a really good point
George because here's the thing and
here's where I kind of take this is a
lot of people will look at the baby
steps and they'll go I think these are
the most important I think it's the most
important to do baby steps one through
three and then they kind of like go off
on a tangent and do their own thing and
it's like no you don't do the baby steps
based on the ones you think are your
favorite or the ones you think are going
to be the most important you choose to
work the plan or you choose not to work
the plan that's the way I because you
know there's so many things George that
we ask people to do along the way
because we know where they're headed
like we say pause you're investing while
you're paying off debt controversial
it's controversial but we are saying
that because we know what comes next so
if you're the person who's like oh okay
I'm gonna pay off my debt but you're
like lollygagging through it and you're
not being intense like we tell you to
like these are the things that I'm
weighing in my mind they're all
important and if you're going to do this
plan
do this plan I'm gonna I'm going to
render this question as a not good
question oh wow shots fired baby steps
Facebook I'm saying the question that
you need to be asking is not this one
I'm gonna try to figure out a better
question that's fair instead of saying
what baby step do you vote is most
important
maybe the one that you're on
I totally went philosophical on you
that's right the most important one is
where you need to be at if you're in
debt baby step two is the most important
come on somebody if you have no
emergency savings but you don't have any
debt baby step three is the most
important I will say that you where your
feet are the Ramsay plan what I love
about it is it's more than about money
it's about transformation it's about
living counter culturally and for that I
will say baby step two is the Crux of
the plan 100 most people never most
people go through their life and never
pay off all their debt they're a dead
wolf they'll always that's the most
confusing it's the most like wait what
you want me to get at all debt like cut
up the credit cards yeah and uh you know
Romans 12 2 do not be conformed to the
pattern of this world be transformed by
the renewing of your mind that's right
baby step two is the most
transformational renewing of the Mind
paradigm shift I can think of when you
go oh my gosh this whole world of debt
and the culture and the marketing and
consumerism it's like we're living in
the simulation yeah and if we can just
unplug and go I don't have to be a part
of that I can live on my terms I can
live with freedom and peace and joy and
margin options and meaning that is what
getting out of debt does for you and
then the next steps are kind of like
okay cool now we can have some money in
the bank and be investing for the future
and kind of get these things on
autopilot yeah yeah I agree with you
wholeheartedly
um I think the next controvers like baby
step two definitely different from what
culture would teach I even think baby
step six a little bit the idea of paying
off your home mortgage early and the way
we teach a 15-year fixed rate mortgage
is economy Jade are you kidding me they
live in an alternate universe where you
could get a 15 yes math hasn't changed
since history has began I'm sorry uh so
that's a very controversial one it is
what do you think is the hardest one oh
I think baby step three is the hardest
because you're you're done paying for
the past but you're not quite ready to
build for the future yes and it's just
this not non-excitement Midway point in
the marathon there's no one's cheering
you on there's no live band you're just
kind of on your own yeah
debt during baby step two you've spent
all this time sacrificing let's be
honest you want to give yourself a
little something something and you're
like I don't come on can I just it's
time to treat yourself that's right it's
not time to treat yourself oh my
goodness that's a fun conversation